Vodafone, Vodafone, was ist hier los? Ey, das ist so schlecht. So ein Kackladen, Mann. Das ist ein Schrott, ey.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, ich würde es keinem empfehlen, i3. Ich mag keine, also ich bin ja nicht der super Tastatur-Only-Verfechter, das gar nicht.
Ich mache hier beispielsweise meine Splits und so zum Einstellen mache ich trotzdem mit der Maus.
Mein Browser bediene ich auch mit der Maus. Aber was ich an i3 mag, ist, dass i3 halt einfach so gut wie nicht da ist.
i3 ist halt, ist halt nicht im Weg. i3 ist halt einfach, einfach so wenig wie notwendig, ja.
Wo du die Wallpaper herbekommst, die Wallpaper bekommst du bei mir auf Shithub.
Da gibt es nämlich ein extra Repo für.
White Paper Happy Desktop.
Da hast du alle, alle Wallpaper.
Credits gehen natürlich nicht an mich, sondern an ihn.
Du hast, wenn du i3 verwendest, sogar ein mehr oder weniger advancedes, nach Uhrzeit gehendes Background Change Script.
Das ist das, was ich auch verwende, der alle 10 Minuten den Hintergrund wechselt, zur Tageszeit passend, eines der Bilder auswählt.
Aber das musst du nicht verwenden, kannst du auch manuell setzen.
Neu am Lästern, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich bin Linux Mint nicht verkehrt, zumal es auch auf Debian,
basiert, basierte, glaube ich, auf Ubuntu früher.
Ich glaube mittlerweile auf Debian.
Also das habe ich nie gemacht.
Ein DSL-Router.
Ich hatte, ich hatte mal in der KVM, hatte ich ein OpenSense laufen und habe darüber Internet-Router gemacht.
Das war mir aber alles viel zu sehr Single Point of Failure, die Kiste.
Nico, danke für den Sub.
Pog.
Subscription.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Sag mal, wie oft ist der Streamer heute abgekackt?
Fünfmal bestimmt, oder?
XFCE ist das einzige an Desktop-Dingern, was ich halbwegs ertrage, wenn es nicht i3 sein kann.
Aber auch XFCE ist, boah, alles eklig.
Ich hatte mal eine Suse, Suse, weiß nicht was es war, so Suse 4 gab es.
Suse, da habe ich nämlich, das war noch zu Zeiten, wo es von Suse Professional und Personal Edition gab.
Das eine waren rote CDs und das andere waren irgendwie...
blaue CDs, habe ich damals auch ausprobiert, ja, ganz, ganz lange her.
Das müsste irgendwie 2000 rum gewesen sein.
Das war mein allererster Kontakt mit Windows, äh, mit Linux damals.
Der war aber nur kurz, weil ich habe das installiert, festgestellt, mein DSL-Modem geht nicht und dann habe ich wieder Windows installiert.
Hehehe, das war alles.
So sah mein erster Linux-Kontakt aus.
Damals, damals hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich mal mit Linux mein Geld verdiene.
Garantiert nicht.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Ohne, ohne ASCII-Quarium geht da nix.
Ripstream, ja.
Du hast OpenSuse, ernsthaft?
Ei, ei, ei.
Aber ich denke mir, jedem was ihm da gefällt, ja.
Also ich mache um Suse ganz großen Bogen.
Was hältst du von Dualboot Windows plus Linux?
Es ist die Frage, was du machen willst.
Also pauschal, für mich, also...
Ne, pauschal kann man es nicht beantworten.
So muss man das sagen.
Für mich ist es nix.
Ich benutze lieber Windows als Host und Linux in der VM.
Weil das, was ich in Linux mache, hat in der VM überhaupt keine Performance-Probleme.
Gut, ich muss sagen, meine VM ist auch, ähm, ordentlich ausgestattet mit 8 CPU-Cores, 24 GB RAM, also mehr als manche Nicht-VM-PCs haben.
Also, was teilweise manche Hosts nicht haben, aber trotzdem, für mich ist der Vorteil davon, also du siehst hier, ich habe sie in der VM, ja, halt im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop, für mich ist der Vorteil, dass ich die beiden Systeme parallel benutzen kann und in jeweiligen Systemen das machen kann, was eben gut funktioniert.
Unter Windows kann ich streamen, kann ich meine Videos machen, wenn ich denn mal welche mache, kann ich Sachen spielen.
Ohne, dass ich mich im Vorfeld damit beschäftigen muss, okay, geht das jetzt oder geht das nicht.
Muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Und unter Linux mache ich alles, was Bastelsachen angeht.
Also insofern eigentlich für mich das Beste aus beiden Welten und ich könnte mir das auch gar nicht mehr vorstellen, irgendwie anders zu arbeiten.
Wenn ich Sachen programmiere und mache, machen wir das ausschließlich unter Linux.
Und wenn ab und zu mal irgendwie was gespielt wird oder sonst, dann machen wir es unter Windows.
So, nächstes YouTube-Video.
Wenn es meiner Katz wieder besser geht.
Dann, äh, kann...
Kann ich mich auf irgendwie Sachen wieder konzentrieren.
Ja, ich finde es auch sinnvoller, eine VM zu machen, weil Dual-Boot nervt.
Dual-Boot wäre nur sinnvoll, finde ich, wenn du sagen würdest, ey, ich will eigentlich hauptsächlich unter Linux unterwegs sein,
aber für den Fall der Fälle, dass doch nochmal irgendwas ist, dann Windows.
Den Fall habe ich nicht.
Ich will ja absichtlich beide Systeme gleichermaßen benutzen.
Wenn ich auch in Linux war, dann würde ich das auch machen.
Wenn ich wahrscheinlich dann mehr unterwegs bin.
Je nachdem, wobei, das kann man so nicht sagen, je nachdem, was ich mache.
Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, ich bin in beiden Systemen ungefähr gleich viel unterwegs.
Aber wenn du halt Sachen benutzen möchtest, wie deine Grafikkarte zum Beispiel, dann ist das in der VM nix.
Aber dann brauchst du, also wenn du beispielsweise irgendwelche Machine Learning Sachen machen willst, mit GPU Acceleration spielen willst unter Linux und so, dann ist das natürlich in der VM nix.
Es geht bis zum gewissen Grad auch in der VM.
Aber Grafikkarte durchreichen ist da halt nicht an der Stelle.
Zumindest nicht mit Windows und VMware Workstation.
Oh, okay.
Dass VMware sich wirklich aufhängt, ist sehr weird.
Ja, VMware Tools kann auf jeden Fall nicht schaden.
Bist du dir sicher, dass sich VMware aufhängt und nicht dein Linux irgendwelche Schmerzen hat?
Weil das ist, das ist sehr merkwürdig.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich mache es auch lieber mit, mit, äh, vm.
Ja, daheim natürlich nicht.
Ich mag Gnome auch überhaupt nicht.
Und ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob es Gnome oder Genome eigentlich ausgesprochen wird.
Ich mag es aber auch nicht.
Ich finde Gnome ist zu, ist viel zu, wie soll man das nennen?
Versucht zu Apple mäßig zu sein oder, wobei das ja nicht stimmt.
Das lassen sich ja nicht mal bedienen wie Apple.
Gnome versucht, glaube ich, zu userfreundlich zu sein für absolute Kacknoobs.
Die aber Gnome auch nicht.
Ich würde Gnome auf dem Desktop eh nicht verwenden würden.
Ich, ich kann Gnome schlecht beschreiben.
Ich, ich mag es nicht.
Ich mag aber auch KDE nicht.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, KDE oder Gnome, würde ich wahrscheinlich KDE benutzen.
Aber ich hätte auf beides absolut keinen Bock.
Für mich, für mich kommt eigentlich aktuell nur i3 in Frage.
Und wenn es wirklich was mit Fenster sein muss, dann vielleicht noch XFCE.
Aber ich könnte mir da auch nicht vorstellen, drinnen länger zu arbeiten.
Bei i3, das Gute bei i3 ist einfach, es, guckt, ah, guckt sich an.
Hier kommt einem einfach nix in den Weg.
Ja, so.
Ich hab, ich mein, was brauchst du, was brauchst du mehr?
Ich hab rechts ein Terminal.
Oh, rechts ein Terminal am Start.
Ich hab meine IDE zum Entwickeln links.
Also ich kann hier den, ich kann hier den Kram ausführen, wenn ich ihn ausführen muss.
Ich kann hier am Backend schrauben.
Und mach ich irgendeine Frontend-JavaScript-Geschichte, hab ich halt noch einen vierten Desktop auf.
Mit Visual Studio Code und dem HTML-Kram.
Und dann halt hier noch den passenden, passenden Browser dazu offen.
So.
Und nachdem das alles wunderbar getrennt ist, von Desktop zu Desktop, kann ich auch super umschalten.
Sag ich, okay, ich muss ins Terminal mal ein bisschen was längeres machen.
Gehe ich auf den zweiten Desktop, ich muss in den Browser.
Dann gehe ich in den ersten Desktop.
Ich muss in meine IDE, wo ich Backend-Sachen mach, hier hin.
Oder ich muss Frontend-Sachen machen.
Das ist super easy, ja.
Ich hab mich da auch schon komplett dran gewöhnt.
Dazu kommt, dass es eben dadurch, dass i3 einem nicht so in den Weg kommt, recht kassiert.
Dass der MySable ist.
Die Leiste hier oben ist komplett austauschbar.
Also, die sieht nicht nur bei mir so aus, weil ich die, das ist, kann jeder so einstellen, wie er will.
Man kann sogar unterschiedliche Programme benutzen, die diese Leisten generieren.
Fluxbox hab ich früher benutzt.
War auch ganz okay.
Openbox war das, glaub ich, noch.
Oder Fluxbox, ich weiß nicht.
Hab ich, hab ich eine Weile benutzt, tatsächlich.
Ja, war auch ganz okay.
So.
Und, was wollen die Stände jetzt?
Was?
Ja.
So, jetzt, für mich ist das, für mich ist das hier top, so, in der Zusammengelung.
Ja, und man kann halt auch die Sachen schön customizen, ja.
Die Leiste ist, customize eigenes Terminal.
Hier, das, den, den App-Launcher oder wie man das nennt, kann ich theoretisch sogar Fenster suchen, ne.
Kann ich sagen, okay, auf welchem Desktop hab ich denn meinen Visual Studio Code.
kann das auswählen, dann springt er auch dahin.
Verwende ich aber nie, weil ich weiß, wo ich meine Fenster
habe. Dann habe ich
noch Copy-Paste, meine letzten
Pastes, die ich durchsuchen kann.
Okay.
Und ein paar Skripts, die ich ausführen kann,
die ich manchmal brauche. Aber ich
mag das.
Was ist dein Tipp für ESP-Dev-Boards für
Hobby-Projekte? Habe ich tatsächlich
eins. Also, wenn du einfach nur ein Board
haben willst, was funktioniert,
der All-Time-Klassiker ist
tatsächlich immer noch
das Ding. Finde ich.
So. Da kannst du eigentlich
nicht großartig was mit falsch machen.
Was ich
allerdings sehr praktisch
finde,
ist das Ding,
weil,
das musst du dir irgendwo bei AliExpress
kaufen, da kostet es 8 Euro oder so.
Kannst du ja auch gleich strukturieren. Das hat ein
Display dabei. Das hat quasi
genug GPIOs,
aber es
hat ein Display dabei.
Und ein schönes
Display. Nicht so ein billiges
Display. Kein monochromes
Ding. Es ist ein Farbdisplay drauf,
wie man hier sieht.
Die ESP32 haben alle
WiFi und Bluetooth. Du kannst dir
auch überlegen, ob du dich
einen noch neueren ESP32
holst.
Weil die haben mittlerweile, glaube ich, sogar
welche mit WiFi 5.
Ich habe schon
eine ganze Weile nicht mehr geguckt,
was es da alles gibt.
S2, S3
und so.
S2, den
verwendet, glaube ich, keiner.
C6 ist, glaube ich, der
interessante.
Ne, S3.
Irgendeiner davon hat neuere
Bluetooth-Spezifikationen.
Genau, der hat BLE
5.
Und irgendeiner davon konnte
da nicht auch irgendeine SIGBI
von? Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ja.
S1 Minis habe ich ja auch noch in der Ladung liegen.
Die sind auch okay.
Ich persönlich mag das halt mit dem Display.
Ja, Chico geht es nicht gut.
Chico hat alle... Wobei,
heute Abend geht es hier echt schon
minimal besser, muss man sagen.
Also, Chico hat Blutdruck,
hat zu hohen Blutdruck, Nierenprobleme,
Schilddrüsenprobleme, zu wenig
rote Blutkörperchen. Also,
Chico ist echt...
Der geht es nicht gut.
Tierarzt weiß auch nicht mehr,
was wir machen sollen.
Die Sache, die wir jetzt haben, ist
ein bisschen weniger Blutdruck-Medikamente
und
die kriegt jetzt so eine Paste,
das ein bisschen appetitanregend sein soll.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie lange das gut geht.
Was benutzt du als Backup-Lösung
privat? Dankeschön für den Sub übrigens.
Tatsächlich relativ
easy mode AirSync.
Flexterne Platte.
Also auf meinem Nass.
Ja.
Chat ist
natürlich auch wieder Tierarzt.
Wie ich sehe, schon.
Lull, Alter.
Chat kann alles.
Chat ist Anwalt
und Tierarzt in einem.
Hier hast du mal gemeint, du nutzt nur Windows.
Okay, ist das so?
Was erzählst du von Dualboot Windows
plus Linux?
Es ist die Frage, was du machen willst.
Also,
pauschal für mich...
nee, pauschal kann man es nicht beantworten.
So muss man das sagen.
Für mich ist es nix.
Ich benutze lieber Windows.
Was erzählst du von Dualboot?
Ja, gut, hast du abgeschnitten an der Stelle.
Toll.
Das hat mir nicht so gut gefallen.
Das ist sehr merkwürdig, wenn sich dein Linux
ohne das groß was drauf ist, aufhängt.
Falls du dich dran erinnerst, ich habe das Konzept
für meine Abschlussprüfung ein bisschen mehr ausgearbeitet
bezüglich Switch Backup für...
Ja, ja, erinnere ich mich dran.
Habe jetzt mit Git und Git
ein lokal... Man kann jetzt aus...
Konfigurations...
Das ist nice, aber...
Wie gesagt, du musst das der IHK
so verkaufen, dass es nicht
schon fertig ist, sondern dass du die Lösung
für ein Problem suchst.
Und dann zeigen, wie du zu
der eigentlichen Umsetzung
dann halt kommst, ja.
Mit Produktauswahl und alle möglichen...
Also, es bringt in der Regel fast
nix, bei Projekten
unnötig Sachen anzuflanschen, dass
sie noch komplizierter werden.
Es braucht ein passendes Projekt.
Und fast jedes Projekt ist passend.
Wenn der Titel und der Umfang
richtig gewählt ist,
dass da genug von dem drin ist, was
die IHK sehen will.
Ja, ja, die 3 braucht nix.
Ja, mit macOS würde ich es
wahrscheinlich genauso machen, ja.
Was sagst du eigentlich zu Arts Delivery?
Die haben es echt verkackt
bei Arts Delivery, ne?
Die hätten sich einfach Eats Delivery
nennen sollen, aber auf die Idee sind sie nicht gekommen.
Easy.
Eats Delivery wäre
viel nicer gewesen, vom Namen her.
Was, die sich momentan alle möglichen
Modellbezeichnungen von Chips als Marken...
Hä? Wie kannst du dir was als Marke
eintragen lassen, wenn du
das nicht erfunden hast, quasi?
Was kannst du an Shelly
Empfehlungen geben?
Ja, okay, es gibt
eine...
eine Sache, die bei Shelly wirklich unterschätzt
ist, den ich auch kaum sehe,
das sind die Shelly Uni Dinger.
Die sind...
billig und für
klein und für
kleine Sachen super, super
geeignet, wo man mehrere Inputs braucht.
Ja.
Aber die sind nicht zum
Schalten von 230V mit Relay
oder sowas. Was ist an Shelly?
Die meisten Leute
kennen von Shelly
am ehesten
diese Dinger.
Das sind Relays,
die man quasi
unter den Lichtschalter machen kann,
also nicht wirklich so, wie er das da
zeigt. Den kann man unter den Lichtschalter
machen.
Das ist WeirdChamp.
Was die da zeigen.
Den kann man
unter den Lichtschalter machen.
Genau.
Und dann schaltet der Lichtschalter
nicht mehr direkt das Licht, sondern
der Lichtschalter schaltet den Shelly.
Der Shelly schaltet den Relay
für das Licht
und man kann's mit
WLAN verbinden und man kann das Licht halt auch
schalten. Vom Handy zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Ja, den mein ich. Den meinte ich.
Gibt's den eigentlich lieferbar mittlerweile?
Tatsächlich.
Ich bin geneigt
dazu, den mal auszuprobieren.
So ein eigenes
Zigbee.
Also es wäre
mega, wenn es
mal neues WiFi gäbe. 5G.
5G WiFi für die ESPs.
Du brauchst 12 GPIO
Pins. Okay, da hast du ein etwas
Projekt.
Dafür sind die noch ein bisschen kleiner.
Ja, Vodafone ist am
abkacken.
Wie gesagt, Chat ist auch Tierarzt.
Das hab ich schon mal
gehört. Es gibt ja noch mehr. Es gibt noch AirClone
und alle möglichen Sachen.
Wobei AirClone eher für
Offsite Backup zu irgendwelchen Cloud
Anbietern ist.
Ja, die sind nice, die Dinger.
Aha. Wie lange hab ich jetzt eigentlich
schon gestreamt? Meine Stream Anzeige ist
ja voll im Arsch.
Wollen wir noch
irgendwas auf Youtube
kurz gucken?
Die gefährlichste App
aller Zeiten. Das klingt immer
so nach Drama von
Simplicissimus. Software
ist das Desaster.
Cloud Vergleich.
Wieso wir von Dropbox weg sind.
Mich
wundert es, dass überhaupt noch irgendjemand bei Dropbox
ist, Mann. Dropbox ist so
2017.
Aber dann
schon nett gerechnet. Eher 2015.
Wir sind doch gerade, Leute.
Hatten wir es nicht gerade von
Desktop Environments?
Die Desktop Environment Tierlist.
Das gucken wir jetzt
nochmal schnell.
Den Typ hatten wir doch das letzte Mal auch schon.
Und ich fand seine
Tierlist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist kein Zufall.
Hehehe.
Oh, ich bin
echt voll blatt.
Ich habe gestern überhaupt
nicht richtig gepennt.
Die Nacht von gestern auf heute gar nicht richtig
gepennt, weil ich immer nach der Katze
zwischendurch geguckt habe und irgendwie nicht richtig
schlafen konnte.
Pfeiltransfer zwischen Rechnern
würde ich im Leben nicht Dropbox
verwenden für.
Also, es ist
die Sache. Je nachdem, was man machen
will. Wenn man quasi
gleichzeitig in der Cloud haben möchte
für Mobile Zugriff oder
Backup in Anführungszeichen,
weil meistens ist Cloud Sync kein richtig gutes Backup.
Weil an einer Stelle
gelöscht, überall weg, wenn es keine History
gibt. Und nebenbei, man
es auch noch an beiden Rechnern braucht, ist ja nicht
verkehrt.
Aber wenn ich einfach nur Dateien von einem
zum anderen Rechner übertragen will als
einmalige Aktion,
dann
SCP
R-Sync.
Meinetwegen
FDP.
Der Markt regelt das.
So.
Das wollte ich jetzt hier angucken, aber das wollen wir
zumachen. Schauen wir nochmal.
Die
Linux Desktop
Environment Tierlist.
Gut, man kann auch
einfach I3 verwenden, was kein richtiges
Desktop Environment ist und deswegen auch
nicht nervt. Okay. Ich sag euch
jetzt mal schon, wie meine Tierlist
aussehen würde. Unity ganz
unten. Schrott.
XFCE
Pretty good. Ich weiß nicht,
was das ist. Ist das Cinnamon?
Was ist das? Weiß das jemand
von euch? Sollte das Cinnamon
sein, dann kommt es auch in Pretty good.
KDE.
Ach, das ist Mate. Okay.
Cinnamon ist ganz links.
KDE,
so Durchschnitt.
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung. Das habe ich schon mal.
Ach, das ist LXDE oder sowas.
Das ist, naja, braucht keiner.
Das ist Pretty good und das
weiß ich auch nicht. Okay, dann lassen wir uns das jetzt mal
erzählen.
Resolution and other things.
So, let's actually
put these on a Tierlist. Ja, dann
The desktop environments are a little bit weird
because most of these teams
are only a handful of people.
There's almost, some of them are only
one person, you know. It just depends
on the desktop environment. So
instead of... Wo ist eigentlich GNOME?
Ich würde GNOME
gerne hier unten reinpacken.
... your, you know, Windows
or Mac OS that has hundreds
of people. Ach, das ist lieb in China
Chinesen, desktop, ja. Thousands
and tons of quality assurance. You really
have these small teams making
die GUI, die man in fast jeder Linux-Verteilung sieht.
Also ranken wir sie heute.
Wir fangen direkt damit an und fangen mit Cinnamon an.
Ja, ziemlich gut.
Also ich finde, also wirklich Goat ist für mich hiervon nichts,
weil ich habe euch ja gesagt, mich nerven alle Desktop-Environments.
Aber Cinnamon ist echt ganz gut.
Cinnamon ist eigentlich großartig für einen neuen Anwender.
Ja, finde ich auch.
In, you know, a lot of people love it, but I put it in a pretty good category.
It looks like this on Linux Mint.
The Mint team makes it.
Clem, I think, is one of their lead devs and just amazing tool set.
Probably the most polished out of all the Desktop-Environments.
The only down thing I'd say about Cinnamon is I don't like it.
It doesn't have a whole bunch of functions.
And sometimes I find myself going,
I wish it was a little bit more customizable.
Where you find a lot of these other ones are.
Wenn es customizable ist, dann musst du KDE benutzen.
But at the end of the day, it's very polished.
Probably the most polished.
And I love it for new users.
Ja, ich finde Cinnamon auch gut.
Now, next up is going to be Deepin.
Deepin ist das China-Chinesen-Linux.
Das habe ich im Stream mal ausprobiert.
Und ich muss sagen, erster Eindruck war gar nicht so übel.
Hatte ein relativ konsistentes Look and Feel, was vielen abgeht.
Ja.
Und tatsächlich, auch die Deepin-Apps, die es mitbringt,
ging auch über rudimentäre Funktionen raus.
Ich fand das gar nicht so übel.
Aber trotzdem nicht so, dass ich es verwenden würde.
Es ist ein interessanter Eindruck.
Ich habe ihn noch nicht so viele Male benutzt.
Aber ich möchte es in der mittleren, ziemlich guten Kategorie
in die Mitte legen.
Es macht einen tollen Job beim Skalieren.
Es sieht wunderschön aus.
Es macht einen tollen Job.
Ich mag es dafür.
Aber es ist eher ein komischer Ball.
Nicht so viele Leute benutzen Deepin.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es ziemlich wunderschön.
Und ich hatte keine Probleme damit.
Optisch ist es wirklich ganz gut.
Jetzt ist es elementary.
Elementary?
Als es neu war, habe ich mir gedacht,
oh guck mal, das könnte tatsächlich was sein
für die ganzen Apple-Fanboys,
die gerne Mac unter Linux hätten.
Ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher,
wie sich das weiterentwickelt hat,
ob das noch taugt.
Wo kaufst du dein ESP,
wenn du es schnell haben willst bei Amazon?
Ansonsten kauf dir einen 10er-Pack bei AliExpress,
dann sind die spottbillig.
Wie ein schlechter Mac-Klon.
Es ist eigentlich Pantheon,
das Desktop-Bereich.
Ich glaube, das ist das einzige Elementary-OS,
das mit dem ESP gebaut ist.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich ein paar andere Spins,
die Elementary-OS haben,
für Mac-User, die zu Linux kommen.
Wenn das wirklich eine Sache ist.
Aber ich glaube,
ich weiß nicht.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich auf Pantheon gehe,
denke ich mir,
oh, das fühlt sich schmutzig an
und ich mag es nicht.
Und das ist das Pantheon-Desktop-Bereich.
Es ist nicht unbedingt...
Bester Clipboard-Manager in Linux.
Ich habe Greenclip mit der RoFi-Integration.
Du weißt ja, wie es aussieht, ne?
Hast du ja schon öfters bei mir im Stream gesehen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas copy-paste,
ich copy-paste jetzt die Zeile,
zack, dann habe ich hier meinen Clipboard-Manager.
Den kann ich auch durchsuchen und scrollen
und alles.
Das gefällt mir am besten.
Ganz ehrlich, LXDE...
Warte mal, wird LXDE überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Ist es jetzt nicht LXQT oder so?
Zumindest ganz ehrlich,
ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung
nicht so richtig dafür.
Wie installiert man Home Assistant
einfach mal auf dem Raspberry Pi,
das fertige Image nehmen?
Ja.
Wenn du das da drauf laufen lassen willst,
bietet es sich wirklich an,
das fertige Home Assistant-Image zu nehmen,
weil dann kriegst du Home Assistant OS dabei.
Das heißt, du kannst über das Home Assistant UI
Add-Ons installieren.
Oh nee, ey.
Hat wieder geleckt, oder?
Ich habe es genau gesehen,
es hat wieder geleckt.
Schrott, Alter.
Was ein Schrott, Mann.
Ja, also Raspberry Pi,
also ich würde Home Assistant
tatsächlich den in der Image nehmen,
da kannst du nämlich auch die ganzen Add-Ons
da drüber installieren,
das sind ja auch deine Home- oder Docker-Container
und Betriebssystem-Updates machen
über das Web-UI und sowas.
Also wenn ich Home Assistant nehmen würde,
dann komplette Installation auf dem Raspberry Pi,
das Image von denen
und am besten auf einer SSD,
weil auf einer Micro-SSD geht das auch.
Du brauchst halt,
also es geht ohne Probleme auf einer Micro-SSD,
du brauchst aber halt eine gescheite,
weil die ganzen Logbücher und sowas,
die da kamen,
die das schreibt,
also da schreibt der relativ,
also Logbuch heißt das im,
in der Web-Interface im Prinzip,
schreibt Home Assistant sehr viel
in der SQLite-Datenbank.
Das muss schon so eine Endurance,
frag mich nicht,
sonst was klasse Micro-SSD sein,
aber SSD ist am besten.
Great for lightweight,
I think it runs on like a 100
or 200 Megs in memory.
I think LXDE is a little bit lighter weight.
Moment, was war das jetzt überhaupt,
was er da hingezogen hat?
Ist das LXQT?
Much of the same here.
It's great for lightweight.
I think it runs on like a 100
or 200 Megs in memory.
I think LXDE is a little bit lighter weight.
LXQT?
GitHub.
Ah ja.
Sieht ein bisschen durcheinander aus.
Wie gesagt, ich mag's alle nicht.
LXQT, BIP.
LXQT, but not by much.
They're both very lightweight
and great desktop environments.
Was ist das?
Ist das Twitter Desktop?
Minimal systems like Netbooks.
If you want to throw it on a potato,
these are usually what you use.
And then we have Budgie.
Budgie ist das?
I put it in a pretty good category.
I was always really impressed with this.
Ich habe nie,
ich habe Budgie nie verwendet.
Die haben diese komische Sidebar,
die man bei Windows auch hat
und schon unter Windows keiner verwendet,
nur dass sie hier ein bisschen sinnvoller erscheint
mit Sound Settings und sowas drin.
Weil ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden,
warum gibt es,
ach so, ja, okay,
also,
ne, mittlerweile ist das tatsächlich alles eins, ne?
Unter Windows, unter Windows 11 war das noch nicht das,
unter Windows 10 war das noch nicht das Gleiche.
Also,
also,
oh,
aber hier,
ich glaube auch hier,
sondern ich mache das halt jetzt,
ichileri,
ichhhh,
ich vi Chie,
ich messed,
ichhihi,
ichiche,
ichamtem nimmer,
Nicht.
Ach.
Gnome.
Some people would put it right here.
Like, some people are like Gnome-Fanatics.
I hate Gnome, though.
I put it in the Dog-Water-Kategorie.
Du musst auf die Glocke klicken.
Der habe ich doch hier.
...Kategorie.
For my personal opinion.
And I do that not because of functionality.
The functionality is there with Gnome.
And it's probably, again, pretty polished.
The one downside to Gnome that I see
and where I just can't bring it to put it in any other tier
other than Dog-Water
is it just installs extensions through the browser.
And I hate that.
That can be exploited.
There's been a lot...
Okay, kann ich verstehen, dass er das nicht mag.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Gnome hatte eine Zeit lang nicht mal ein Fenster-Minimieren-Button.
Das war nicht Usability genug für die.
Actually, quite a few exploits for Gnome
and using actual extensions through Firefly
or a Chromium-based browser.
And you can exploit it through there.
And, you know, a lot of times...
Hat es das immer noch nicht? Kann sein.
...when you do feature updates to Gnome,
the past extensions, then break.
It's just not a great system.
I don't like it.
Now, if you're a purist and don't need any extensions with Gnome
and you just love the layout,
by all means, stick with it.
It's fine for...
Denke ich auch.
Das ist ja eines der Riesenvorteile, was Linux angeht.
Es gibt halt einfach für jeden irgendwas.
Und jeder kann auch einen eigenen Desktop machen.
Wer das denn kann?
Ich mag Gnome nicht.
For those purists out there,
I just don't like the standard workflow of Gnome
and adding extensions with Gnome is ugly.
I really wish they'd change it.
This is cute fish OS.
Never used it.
So we're just gonna toss it down here.
Kenn ich auch nicht.
KDE.
Das dachte ich mir.
Ich hab fast vermutet, er packt es da oben hin,
weil er ist ja ein ziemlicher KDE-Fan.
...would just drop it into the go.
It's probably my favorite desktop environment.
However,
I gotta put it in a pretty good category.
Because there's bugs with it.
You know, there's a lot of functionality here.
It's just not quite as polished as,
I'd say, even Budgie or Cinnamon.
But man, there's...
Aber du kannst halt bei KDE alles konfigurieren.
Na, alles nicht, aber sehr customizable.
KDE-Menüs von früher waren halt
das krasse Gegenteil von Gnome-Menüs, ja?
Wenn du in, sag mal,
ins Gnome-Terminal damals,
als du gegangen bist,
konntest du einstellen,
Hintergrundfarbe, Schriftgröße, Schrift.
Bist du in Konsole gegangen bei KDE damals,
hast du erst mal 15 Untermenüs zum Ausklappen.
A lot of options.
Coming from Windows,
it's by far my favorite desktop environment.
It feels more like it.
You can customize almost anything.
It's great.
And I love it.
But at the same time,
I understand it does have a few flaws,
a little shortcomings,
that I don't really run it on,
on a daily basis anymore.
But I did for a long time and I loved it.
I had many desktops with KDE.
Still love the KDE team.
They're just great.
Next up is Mate.
I'm gonna put this in the average realm.
It,
das heißt einfach nur Mate.
It's a little bit lighter weight than KDE or Gnome.
Like Gnome and KDE are relatively heavy.
Ich finde, Mate geht auch halbwegs klar.
Genau.
Mate ist nämlich Gnome 2, Gnome 2-Fog.
Zu Zeiten, wo man Gnome noch verwenden konnte.
Und Mate ist ein bisschen leichter.
Es ist eigentlich auf dem Gnome 2.0 basiert.
Aber es hat...
Nee, Unity gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ubuntu verwendet jetzt auch irgendeinen Gnome Reskin.
Old school feel.
Also, viele Vets lieben wirklich Mate.
Und es ist nicht schlecht.
Ich habe es einfach in den Average Realm gesetzt.
Nächster Punkt ist Unity.
Schrott.
Das ist nur Hühnerwasser.
Ich denke, es wurde seit vielen Jahren deprägiert.
Und dann kam es aus dem Nichts,
wie Version 7,
aus der Gemeinschaft,
und dann wurde jemand es aufgenommen
und dann wurde es überlebt.
Also, hell ja.
Das ist großartig.
Ich liebe es, diese alten Sachen zurückzuholen.
Es war tatsächlich...
Wie Windows und Würfel auf dem Desktop und sowas.
Fenster, die abrennen.
Unity, Desktop, GitHub.
Hat es auch einen GitHub-Link?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Developed by Ubuntu.
And I actually didn't mind it.
I liked it actually better than Gnome back in the day.
But it being not well supported,
kind of makes me go on,
I probably should steer clear of this.
However, there is some charm to it.
I will admit that.
And then XFCE.
Um...
Man...
Ich würde XFCE,
wenn es unbedingt sein muss,
wahrscheinlich auch hier...
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich hier oben reinpacken.
Aber XFCE ist auch ein ziemlich zusammengestückeltes Ding.
Also...
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, ist alles Schrott. Alles Schrott.
I3 ist das einzige, was bei mir hier oben reinkommt.
If you...
If you just install stock XFCE like this...
Ugh, it's ugly.
Ja, es sieht halt aus,
wie 1995.
But when you do like a full customization of XFCE,
it's pretty nice.
I put it in a pretty good tier.
This is kind of my desktop environment tier list.
Now you might notice,
I didn't put anything in the top tier.
What the hell is going on with that?
Wisst ihr mal,
der Typ ist mir mit...
Also mit den Listen, die ich bisher gesehen habe,
ich gehe nicht bei allem mit.
Aber das...
Ich kann das bei ihm nachvollziehen.
Und es geht in die gleiche Richtung,
wie ich das auch sehe.
Ja.
Ich kann auch nichts hier oben reinpacken,
ehrlich gesagt.
Für mich ist nur I3 da oben.
Und I3 ist ja kein wirkliches Desktop-Environment.
Und ist sogar unfair miteinander zu vergleichen,
weil wenn man zum Beispiel sich mal KDE anguckt,
steckt um ein Vielfaches mehr Aufwand in KDE drin,
als in I3.
Ich meine, guck mal, was alles zu KDE gehört,
versus I3.
Also I3 sind was weiß ich,
ein paar hundert oder tausend Zeilen Code.
Und KDE plus die ganzen Projekte sind Millionen.
Der ist mir schon mal nochmal sympathisch.
Ich meine,
das ist vielleicht dann auch unbedingt das,
was ich verwenden würde.
Aber das geht mit I3 schon auf jeden Fall in die Richtung.
Ist DWM nicht in Haskell programmiert oder sowas?
DWM hatte doch irgendwie so eine weirdchampige Sache.
DWM ist in C?
Dann bring ich es durcheinander.
Genau, das habe ich gemeint, ja.
Just pulling up a terminal
and flipping over to a new workspace
and just doing it all through a window manager.
So, you know,
maybe I put some window managers
with proper customization in the goat category,
but there's no desktop environment
that just really does it for me these days.
And that's where I'm going to leave
the Linux desktop environment tier list.
They're all really fun to do.
So, I encourage you to check them all out
and you can just install, you know,
Vanilla Debian
and then just install any one of these.
Ich finde,
das deckt sich doch ganz gut
mit meinen Ansichten, ja.
Da merkt man auch bei dem,
dass der die Sachen schon mal ausprobiert hat
und nicht einfach nur, wie sagt man so,
sich da was aus dem Ärmel schüttelt,
die Finger saugt.
Ja.
Das habe ich jetzt ein paar Mal auch schon gehört im Chat.
Er wieder.
Du verwendest das doch gar nicht.
Der Chainlaw erzählt das auch immer.
Niemand von euch verwendet Herbstluft-WM, Leute.
Ich kenne niemanden, der das benutzt.
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Anscheinend gibt es das noch.
Das wurde erst vor zwei Monaten geupdatet.
In welcher Programmiersprache ist das?
Hyperland finde ich mega.
Interessant.
Nicestes Projekt.
Finde ich wirklich mega spannend.
Leider Wayland-only
und sehr hardware-affin.
Und es geht in der VM nicht.
Sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch schon mal Hyperland
ein bisschen mehr benutzt.
Ich meine, mit Debian,
mit i3 ist ja nichts dagegen einzuwenden.
Wobei ich ja,
auf dem Desktop,
für mich gibt es zwei Sachen.
Das hatte er tatsächlich auch bei sich
in der Tierlist das letzte Mal.
Es gibt zwei S-Tier-Distributionen.
Arch-Linux für den Desktop,
Debian für den Server. Fertig.
Man könnte jetzt vielleicht für Business Enterprise
Sachen noch argumentieren,
da was anderes reinzupacken.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Debian auf dem Server,
Arch auf dem Desktop und fertig.
Nvidia-Treiber sind Shit unter Linux.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich mache Linux in der VM.
Aber je nachdem, was du machen willst,
das ist das Wichtige für dich.
Muss man schon dabei sagen.
Für mich ist es das beste Setup.
Ich habe VM
immer auf dem zweiten Desktop
im Fullscreen.
So sieht das bei mir immer aus.
Beim Fullscreen schalte ich um.
Also easy, zwischen
zu wechseln.
Und nachdem ich der VM auch ordentlich CPU
und ordentlich RAM und ordentlich Disk
gegeben habe,
habe ich damit auch keine Performance-Probleme.
Sofern man sich im Rahmen dessen bewegt,
kann man es gut mit der VM machen.
Bisschen 3D-Beschleunigung in der VM.
Wir können z.B. diesen
Uni-Heaven-Engine-Benchmark
Wie heißt der?
Uni-Engine-Heaven-Engine-Benchmark
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder?
Dieser Teslation-Benchmark,
den früher immer alle verwenden haben.
Den kann man beispielsweise auch
in der VM laufen lassen.
Der läuft mit 300 FPS richtig gut.
Das liegt aber auch an der ordentlichen Grafik,
die ich darunter habe.
Aber insgesamt gibt es auch viel.
Man kann natürlich auch
Sender starten in der VM,
aber da fängt es schon an, Probleme zu machen.
Also muss man halt gucken.
Für Super Tox Card reicht es auch noch.
Also ich glaube,
ich hatte noch nie den Fall,
dass mir irgendeine Debian-Kiste
bei einem Update abgekackt ist.
Noch nie.
Ich hatte bei Arch Linux selten schon mal Probleme.
Auf dem Desktop halt.
Und Arch Linux hatte auch vielmehr
Bleeding Edge-Pakete.
Bei einem Package-Upgrade.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich nicht an
einen Fall erinnern, wo bei Debian
bei einem Package-Update jemals was kaputt war.
Der Scheiß funzt einfach.
Ist Looking Glass
nicht diese Geschichte mit
aus der VM
aus der VM irgendwelche
Sachen rüber kopieren auf den anderen
Monitor oder sowas?
Ist das der Ubuntu CE?
Die Ubuntu Christian Edition!
Mit Bibel!
Jawoll!
Moment, Patreon, wie viele Leute spenden dafür?
Okay, nicht so viele, aber...
Weil du mit TempleOS nichts anfangen kannst.
Mit Ubuntu Christian Edition
kannst du ja
wenigstens gescheit arbeiten.
Auf einem Thinclient?
Proxmox? Das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Du willst doch
auf einem Thinclient nichts großartig virtualisieren.
Die sind ja meistens
recht schwachbrüstig.
Oder meinst du, das ist einfach nur ein kleiner PC...
Ah, okay. Du meinst, das ist einfach nur ein kleiner
PC, der ordentlich Leistung hat, aber halt
klein, klein gebaut ist.
Dann musst du dich entscheiden, wo du
halt hauptsächlich deinen Fokus drauf
legst. Ist es eher Virtualisierung?
Du willst dich um Containermanagement
und Netzwerkshares
und Sachen alles
selbst kümmern? Oder willst du
eher dann Proxmox? Oder willst du eher so eine
All-in-One-Lösung, dann Unraid?
Wobei das im Virtualisierungsbereich
nicht ganz so gut ist, dann wie Proxmox.
So eine ultimative Lösung
für alles gibt es nicht.
Ja, genau dafür benutze ich es auch.
Alle meine Technik, Bastelsachen
und mein Programmiergedöns mache ich
unter Linux in der VM.
Und Streaming,
Videobearbeitung und Spielen mache ich
unter Windows. Das ist für mich das Beste aus
beiden Welten und ich kann mir das
auch gar nicht mehr anders vorstellen,
als so zu arbeiten.
Ja.
Das ist für mich wirklich die beste Kombination.
Man nimmt einfach das Beste aus beiden
Welten und das, wo die jeweiligen
Systeme ihre Stärken haben.
Ne, ich mag WSL nicht.
WSL fühlt sich immer so
so fremd an. Ich kann es nicht schlecht
beschreiben.
WSL ist immer noch besser als nix.
WSL ist immer noch besser als Batch unter Windows
oder so. Aber
irgendwie fühlt sich
WSL fremd an.
Das ist schwer zu beschreiben.
Hängt schon an, wenn du auf deine Dateien
zugreifen willst, dass du da noch
MNT, C, User
und so
gehen musst.
Und auch der Interop mit den Windows-Programmen
macht teilweise ein bisschen Probleme. Also
ganz ehrlich, WSL, ja, wenn sonst nix geht,
aber irgendwie fühlt es sich immer noch ein bisschen
fremd an.
Das stimmt wohl, wobei ich halt
ehrlich sagen muss,
nein, habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Beim letzten Arbeitgeber, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
war hauptsächlich Azure angesagt, aber jetzt
ist es eher Google dort, wo ich bin.
Also ich habe mit Azure jetzt das letzte
Dreivierteljahr nicht mal viel gemacht.
Ja, okay.
Dualboot, wenn man Performance-Sachen testet,
das verstehe ich. Ja, das macht ja auch Sinn.
Die VM,
das stimmt wohl. Ja, die ist nicht
ganz so performant wie vielleicht jetzt Native.
Wobei man sagen muss, mit meinem
i3-Setup hier, den 8
CPU-Kern in 24 GB RAM,
also, man merkt
den Unterschied nur gar nicht, also man
merkt ihn, das will ich jetzt gar nicht
bestreiten.
Aber es ist schon
echt nicht
ein großer Unterschied zu Native.
Hast du eine externe Soundkarte?
Ja, habe ich.
Ein Motu Track 16,
das habe ich Jahre schon.
Was für ein Dick!
Ne, Entra heißt doch nur
Azure AD,
heißt Entra, oder?
Azure heißt immer noch Azure.
Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Kostet VMWare eigentlich was?
VMWare Workstation kostet
was, ja. Aber
du findest sehr günstig
Keys bei Keysellern.
Oder woanders.
Ich habe das damals auch gekauft bei
einem Keyseller.
Für 8,50 oder sowas.
Korrekt!
Ja, ja, das ist richtig.
Ich persönlich mag
VMWare einfach lieber als VirtualBox.
VirtualBox würde es unter anderem
bei Windows auch tun.
Ich kann jetzt gar nicht so sagen,
so nach dem Motto, VirtualBox funktioniert
überhaupt nicht, deswegen nehmt VMWare.
Ne, das nicht.
Aber gerade wenn es darum geht,
vielleicht ein bisschen
2D, 3D Acceleration zu bekommen
in der VM,
dann sind
die VMWare Treiber doch schon
eine ganze Ecke besser.
Hyper-V, kannst knicken dafür.
Ja, Snapshots sind dann
eine der coolsten Sachen an der VM.
Ja, aber der Player zum angucken
reicht es auf jeden Fall, aber
man kann sich
für ein Apfel und ein Ei beim Key-Shop
VMWare Key kaufen.
Oder ich glaube, man kann sogar 30 Tage
Trial machen bei VMWare, wenn ich nicht falsch liege.
Hyper-V ist ja auch
nix für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Okay, Leute.
Spontaner Stream mit 3x
Vodafone-Kacke zwischendrin.
Ich bin übelst kaputt.
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Key for VMware Workstation.
Genau.
Habe ich mir irgendwie für 8,50 gekauft.
Betge Boomer müde.
Korrekt.
Boomer müde, Boomer Betge.
Wo habe ich denn
mein Betge-Emote eigentlich, Leute?
Hier. VMware Workstation kostet
was, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Deswegen habe ich mir auch bei dem Key-Shop
was gekauft für 8,50 oder irgendwie
8,90 oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, VMware Workstation Pro
habe ich.
8,50 für
ein Key für 8,90.
Ey, dass es Mittel
und Wege gibt, ja, aber da posten wir
hier nix im Chat jetzt.
Weil das ist Monkatos.
Wird das überhaupt noch
weiterentwickelt?
Das Nordkorea-Linux?
Okay. Chat.
Bis morgen. Macht's gut.
See you.